un nuevo giro de 180 grados para el
hombre más rico del planeta
elon musk informó en una carta enviada
Twitter de su intención de comprar la
compañía al precio inicial acordado en
abril es decir 44 mil millones de
dólares esta decisión llega dos semanas
antes del inicio del juicio que opone
las dos partes en abril el director
general de tesla firmó la compra de
Twitter pero poco tiempo después con
célula operación acusando a la red de
mentir sobre el número de cuentas falsas
en respuesta Twitter lanzó un
procedimiento judicial contra el
multimillonario creo que mosc con la
batalla judicial de Delaware que se
avecina reconoció que iba a ser muy
complicado él iba a terminar teniendo
que poseer Twitter de una manera u otra
le ahorró una fea batalla judicial que
estaba prevista para el 17 de octubre
los cargos judiciales en su contra pero
Twitter esperará que la transacción sea
completada antes de hacerlo Twitter
obviamente quiere cerrarlo quiere tomar
54,20 dólares por acción pero no creo
que va a estar dispuesta a poner fin a
los procedimientos en la cancillería de
Delaware hasta que tenga algún tipo de
garantía absoluta de que esto es
realmente honesto tras el anuncio la
acotación de la acción Twitter subió un
22% de concretarse la transacción una de
las plataformas de mayor influencia en
el mundo de las redes sociales quedaría
en manos de mezcla el empresario
contempla privatizar Twitter y sacarla
de la bolsa para tener más margen de
maniobra también espera flexibilizar la
moderación de contenido considera que la
prohibición permanente de usuarios no es
la solución pero lo que más preocupa a
los usuarios es la protección de datos